hi everyone my name is Elam a panda from
Zimbabwe I'm a global changemaker from
the British consul initiative my views
on stating the benefits for the world
cup on Africa and that because I'm a
Zimbabwean i think that the benefits are
temporary because the Buddha's have been
open two Zimbabweans uh with without
further notice really so that means the
moments of future coming to South Africa
and work but the question is how long
would that be sustainable because the
Second World Cup starts the ends above
ones waka have to come back and
obviously the situation still remains
the same at home so the benefits
although our to a great extent right now
in the future they're going to be really
non-existent and Africa will still be in
a position of suffering for the moment I
think that we've put ourselves in a
position as Africa to prove that we're
capable of hosting something this big so
I actually am really proud of South
Africa actually an Africa as a whole for
doing this so I'm behind in full force
but just concerned with what the outcome
of it but yeah